[Music]
we're up to episode 11 here and
demo rpg if you will and today we're
going to be adding potions and then
adding an inventory so let's dive right
into it all right so we have an item
manager and it uh seems to do some
things we're going to make a new
well it uh it's for creating things
we're going to have it do a little more
than that later but for now we just want
a nice a nice way to control how things
are made that way we don't have to worry
about memory leaks and stuff like that
so let's make a new item
uh here static item pointer create
oh [ __ ] so we're gonna make a method to
create potions
well i don't know what hotkey i hit but
it popped up some emoji thing who uses
emojis when coding
visual studio is that a joke
anyway
standard
string
name
so potion needs name of course
and uh
we need to decide what a potion does
uh did definitely it's gonna be like a
buff basically so if we look over at
buff that we designed a while back we
see that every buff
has a name duration the stats it buffs
and whether it's a debuff or not
so we could essentially
just pass it a buff and say hey this is
what it does but
this could also maybe be
nothing maybe it well
we've got a name already that's
interesting
well you know a potion might be called
one thing but the buff it gives might be
called another so it does kind of make
sense to have a name here as well as a
name in the potion
now we obviously haven't designed the
potion yet but we'll get to that just
kind of uh hypothesizing a little bit so
it is going to have rather than core
stats it's going to have a buff
pointer
because we want to compose this we maybe
want to pass null here
so we'll just say
uh a given buff or something like that
or just buffalo okay so that's fine
all right and we also want to know what
else could this potion do it could
potentially heal uh so we might uh want
that so
let's go ahead and put in here uh well
type
um
heal because there's nothing in buff
that says
it could be a heel right now but uh we
do want to know about this so let's go
ahead and be sure to include our types
here include
types
now i was thinking we're using string
all over the place we might want to type
that to something like a text name or
something
but let's just go with this potion here
for now so what we're going to do
basically is if they pass in null here
for this buff
we're going to assume it's not a buff
that it's instead of heal so there's
going to be
multiple different types of potions
maybe some of them give you a buff and a
heel
uh we just kind of got to decide
something there so uh
now
we gotta do the same thing basically we
want to make a new item but this time we
want to make a new potion rather than an
armor or a weapon so let's copy this
down
and let's type potion here and let's
just fill this out with what it would be
oh pressing wrong buttons again buff and
heal
and this will be potion
this should be item oops uh it doesn't
know what potion is yet and that's
intended because we haven't designed
that in our item yet so let's go to our
item and of course we have item delegate
we've got our item here that's the one
we actually use and then down here we
have the whole equipment set up
but now we just want to add a potion to
the mix and see what i did there all
right so let's go ahead and just do that
now what is potion other than
an item so
it's probably going to be fine to let's
think about this here for a second
uh we probably actually want this item
let's see where do we want this item
uh at some point here i'm going to split
this code up i think but let's put item
at the very bottom all right that way we
just kind of keep things separated
okay very good so let's go
class potion
now potion is going to be
inheriting from
the item delegate of course
it doesn't need a whole lot else here
but it is going to have
of course a buff pointer yeah we'll just
call it
uh
maybe i should have underscored i don't
know i don't want to use under just
the keyword buff too much or add the
name buff but it's it's fine we'll just
go with it
yeah we'll just go with it all right and
we need to decide
well type heal doesn't have a heel or
not and we need some sort of constructor
here so let's go ahead and make this
private and we're going to do the same
thing we're doing with these other ones
where uh like this armor
it everything's private all the
constructors are private and it has a
friend class of this item manager
because literally only the item manager
is the only thing that's allowed to
instantiate these and that's just so we
can carefully manage how things are done
so let's just go potion and put some
some data in here
now we know it needs a name so
let's put that in there name and we know
that uh it could potentially have a
a buff of some sort so let's go there
like that but right here we'll just call
b here and
or just be you f leave the f off of
there and uh we know it could
have a heal hp we'll just call it hp
sure that's fine and i'd rather
rename this i think like heel amounts or
something a little just a little clearer
a little clearer uh
thinking
yeah this is probably a better name for
buff but we're just going to leave it
like that you know buffs a little vague
there's a lot of different things that
tend to be called buffs or buffers
things like that all we mean is just
like a temporary
stat boost uh kind of it's like a you
know a standard rpg buff and debuff
terminology there all right so it still
doesn't quite understand what this
potion is so we just need to keep
designing it
and we'll keep going with it here
where's where okay yeah we haven't
finished this so of course it doesn't so
we need to use this item delegate
and say
well go ahead and put the name in there
because we got a little constructor
there that'll take that
so let's just forward that name and we
need to decide what this this buff is
the buff is going to be buff and if it's
null pointer then it's going to turn
into nothing if it's not no pointer
it'll do a thing and heal amount of
course is going to be
hp heal
however you want to type that's fine and
then we have nothing else in there
so there we go we now have a potion
now there's something else
interesting about potions here and that
is well
what if you have multiple potions that
are exactly the same so that's something
we need to think about
because we essentially want to have a
quantity
uh possible for this particular item
so what we can do here is just go
want to d let's see how we're going to
do this quad um we might change this
later but uh for now let's just use a
let's just use an unsigned integer uh 16
will be fine that should be plenty of
space let's go ahead and take a look at
our types see if we got anything
relevant no we don't have
an item count so we might want to let's
just make another type def for item
count because we'll use this over and
over
as we go forward and we just want to
control that a little bit and we'll call
this
quantity so maybe you could find more
than one and we'll assume it makes one
at a time but we could put in here
something like
quantities maybe find a stack of three
or something quantity
and we're going to need a few other
special things i don't need to call this
item count that's the type there well
we'll just call it quant which sounds a
little weird but we'll just assume it's
one so we'll set it to one if they don't
specify and that way in this constructor
let's go ahead and break this to a new
line so we can see what we're doing
and
you know i always forget to
collapse these sides so that you guys
can see better uh
but there we go so let's go quantity
is q
not q sort i don't know why i put that
in there oh autocorrect or something or
quant rather there we go so now we can
pass on a quantity and if we leave that
off it's just gonna default to one to
one and now we need to think about
something else here what if we create
the same potion over and over
then what happens well we need some sort
of comparison operator to say hey is
this exactly the same as some other
potion if so just increase the quantity
and that's something we will address a
little later but for now we're just
going to have the ability to create a
bunch at once potentially because i
think that makes sense
and there we go we now have an item
potion
that can be instantiated
as a an item because we can do it as
this delegate data
uh just the same so if we go back to our
item manager
and we look at potion it uh it's not
happy because it says hey potion is not
allowed there's no pure virtual function
so we can't actually instantiate it yes
yet until we override this particular
little function
and really this function is not
something we're going to use i just
explained that last episode but really
we just need something
to make this pure virtual and we could
have this something like a do not use or
something like that
but uh you know we have ways of casting
this and checking whether it's a potion
or not already so we rarely are going to
need this get type which is kind of cool
thing to do and we might change that
later but what i think we're gonna do
for now is you know we've retyped this
over and over and we if we change it
we're gonna have to change it in a lot
of spots so what we're gonna do is we're
actually gonna make a macro of this so
let's go define
and
we'll call this macro get type in all
caps and what's it going to be it's
going to be
this here
so there we go
and now we have a macro of it ty i could
make it a little nicer looking but yeah
let's not worry about that so instead of
typing this here let's just put the
macro scroll down here and just find
anywhere else where we've put this get
type and just kind of clean up our code
code a little bit like that
we got it right here
oh yeah type
okay clean up a few lines there
and uh item here doesn't have it okay so
yeah that should take care of it it
wants a hint file but i'm not we're not
going to care about that so now if we
ever decide that we're going to change
this function we can just edit this
macro and this here rather than
everything in the class hope that makes
sense but basically just saving us a
little future trouble because uh this is
really just a placeholder
to make sure that's pure virtual and
also
this potion here let's just go ahead and
make it final kind of like we were doing
with the armor and weapons just so it's
a clear that you're not supposed to
inherit from them further
and you know we could do something like
potion types and stuff but that's up to
the design of our game right now we got
a system already that's half decent
where it at least
either heals or buffs and we could even
say here that the heel defaults to one
so if they don't don't specify anything
like if they just pass in a name and
null it's uh the tiniest heel potion of
one and count of one
so this might not be i don't know i'm
kind of thinking maybe we should change
the order of this a little bit because
i kind of like the idea of putting this
buff near the end
and defaulting it to null pointer
and that's going to change how our item
manager works too we will have to do it
like so
but in reality we should probably have
the defaults on this one as well
so let's just fix this up a little bit
quantity
yeah so we have some options in how we
do this basically i'm kind of just uh
picking a method and going with it
quantity
did i spell that right
no i didn't but it also is a
uh item count
now we'll just call it quant again and
we already could call it a mount or
whatever but quantities that feels like
a little more a little more
clear
okay but uh so if we call create potion
you're forced to pass values in here and
it's gonna you know these default values
don't actually do much with the way we
have it designed it's is a thing because
sure we have them here but there's no
way to create it unless we actually use
the item manager which uh doesn't have
default values so it's gonna be passing
on anything so we probably want to if
we're doing default values we'd rather
do it here i'm not sure if this is
actually going to be happy yeah it seems
okay you just need to make sure
they start the whatever has default
values is at the end see uh kind of an
interesting thing you try to put a
default value in the middle it's not
happy because it's not at the end of the
parameter list so yeah that's a thing
and ids will tell you that you don't
have an id that tells you that
then you'll find it out eventually
but we could do similar things for the
create weapon the default values it's
really just totally optional and it
depends on your design so that's what
we're going with here
alright so the potion creates all the
stuff but we need to make sure potion
destructs
properly we know that's really important
we've explained that a lot so
we have this buff pointer that's the
thing we need to make sure destroys if
this potion destroys we want to destroy
that as well however there's something
interesting here that
is going to be a little tricky okay so
you could have multiple potions it could
have multiple quantities so we need to
kind of specifically control this
destructor like if we use a potion
we don't want it to
destroy this memory unless it's the very
last potion
so we need to consider that but that's
going to be something we write later
because in general we're going to we're
going to assume i guess let's get type
here so it doesn't do this weird
have over thing
i guess you know i guess the place to
put your macros is right before one of
these because it doesn't use weird tap
bug that we talked about anyway
so if
uh buff exists we'll just delete uh buff
and set it to null pointer
buff equals null pointer and uh of
course i'm doing this a little wrong i
need to put brackets around it since
it's multi-line there we go so if the
buffer if the buff exists we delete it
if we're getting deleting the last
potion so typically we'll we'll get to
this later but when we use a potion
we'll check the quantity and if there's
if there's more than one we reduce the
quantity if it's the last one we'll use
it and then just and then actually you
know destroy the thing so that should be
fine
all right and i think i might have
messed up somewhere else in here let's
just do a search for star and look at
any pointers we just need to make sure
like here where we're deleting data we
should actually be checking if data
exists first
so a little cleanup there if there is
data then do the whole delete thing that
way it actually
works properly now what people often do
is they'll put in their class somewhere
they'll put like a a
free data function that does this
basically
so
it's optional how you want to do that
but uh you know for example they might
have
uh privately somewhere here static uh
void
free
and uh
they'll do something like
oh what would this be this would be item
delegate star
data
and then they'll you know they'll do
something like this if data
delay you know uh
delete oh data gotta make sure we keep
the functions
now this isn't something you have to do
i just want to show you this because you
see this in a lot of code bases this
sort of thing and rather than all this
they'll just go
three data
and that way it uh it does the null
check and all that stuff and one but uh
and this static function means you know
it doesn't you have to pass it data
and this doesn't get created for
everyone so no matter how many items you
create there's only one free function
it's kind of like an extension so you'll
see extensions like this too
but uh yeah anyway that's a whole nother
topic
and we're just gonna keep it keep it
like so i think it's clean this way
where it just deletes itself it should
handle itself
like manager okay so now we have a way
to create potions let's go ahead and
test out our potions here you know we've
got
elms and all that stuff and
they just equip but we don't have to
wait a way to equip potions or anything
like that but we can always test
creating them and let's go ahead and do
that so let's make a new walk here and
let's just go item
uh i don't know we'll call it a heel
potion
equals item manager
create
potion
uh we'll call it minor
yielding potion sure and we need to pass
it how much it heals we'll say it heals
for
three
and we could say oh it doesn't buff
anything if not we need to pass well
it's got we got defaults here so that's
actually nice we can just leave these
blank doesn't buff anything and its
count will be one
uh if we want to change the count and
you know maybe buff should be last on
this list actually like that let's make
that change real quick we'll go to the
item manager
we'll say
this buff actually is going to happen
last that way we can change
just so we can quickly make healing
potions if we want and
it actually forwards in a different
order let's just uh make that a little
more synchronized here
by doing it like that and then we'll go
to our potion and fix it here as well
there where are we at there we go
there's the buff let's just put this up
again that's all we're doing
that's just personal preference i just
like the idea of if it doesn't have a
buff and you just want to make potions
real quick you can say hey make three of
them like that there's three potions
that heal three and uh very good and
then we can just do a check here let's
see if it works
so we'll go
uh heel potion or
let's say
potion rather potion
pointer
wait a sec how how were we doing this
earlier okay okay so here's the thing we
can't we can't do the cast check here
because we can't we're not allowed to
instantiate potions just let's try it
let's call it pot uh
equals
and we need the dynamic cast stuff
dynamic cast it to a potion pointer
uh and that's the hill potion so we'll
basically you know this this creates an
item
and we want to see of course if it it
possibly can be cast to a potion and
you'll you'll see we'll it's going to be
a little set the operand of runtime
dynamic cast must have a polymorphic
class type which it does
but the thing is
if we go to this potion
it's
constructors private
and it's friend classes item manager so
only the item manager or someone that's
allowed to mess with this is going to be
able to do it
the player character can do it so
that's
that's a thing and maybe later we'll
have a world manager and stuff like that
but right now it's just
totally not allowed
oh wait i'm i'm doing this slightly
wrong actually
uh the heel
potion we actually need its data right
so we have a get data function
but it's const so it's not happy we
could go
const cast uh forget the exact syntax
but yeah we explained we don't want to
do that and
so you're not allowed to dynamic cast
that const but you could
do it like so
dot underscore data but we don't have
access to data it's private and only the
player character and the item manager so
essentially in our main here we're not
allowed to do all this
and
the way we were getting around that
before is we were passing it to
the player character the player
character is a friend class of item
and it's allowed to to mess with the
data so
and the reason we do that
is so people can't do things basically
we're controlling the memory and how the
items work
so that we don't get glitches later in
our game because if you're just leaving
everything wide open
at some point you're gonna you know
could be way further down in your design
and you're gonna get to a point where
you just kind of get things to work
basically and if you've designed it
previously where it's like okay you can
get it to work but only if you do it in
a way that i allow then
people can't mess it up further down the
line i i know that's kind of confusing
and maybe awkward to hear uh as a new
programmer
but that's one of the beauties of c plus
and this whole being able to control
things and putting things in private is
basically you don't let yourself mess up
down the line when like a week later you
come back to work on your project you
may have slightly forgotten exactly what
your plans were if you had previously
designed it with the future in mind of
okay so if someone uses this they got to
do it in a specific way so they can't
mess it up it actually saves you a lot
of time because
you basically reduce the number of bugs
you accidentally introduce as your
software grows
so that's that's the whole point here
and you may let you may love that you
may hate that
but there's a reason it's designed that
way and you should take advantage of it
if you can but that's you know that's a
lot of that's my opinion of course but
it is quite relevant i think
all right well we can make potions but
we can't exactly do anything with them
so kind of like how we have equip
longsword maybe we want like use item
and that
is going to be a thing so let's go into
our player character class player
character where we are here we have an
equip
but let's also
let's do a use a bull
use
and this is also going to pass in an
item
item to use
it's going to be similar in some ways
but we're going to do the casting checks
we need see in this we say is there an
item
does it have data and then we check if
it's armor or weapon
it equips if it's armor or weapon or at
least tries
and this is going to be similar in the
way that well we want these two initial
checks basically
just to make sure there's actually
something
and it returns false if there's nothing
oh call it all you need to use this time
but rather than checking if it's armor
or a weapon this time
you might know where i'm going with this
we just want to check if it's some type
of usable light currently the only thing
we have is potions so let's name all
this potion
potion
ocean this name actually doesn't matter
it's just a temporary name but potion's
fine and we see if it casts to a potion
here we do the null check if this fails
uh we return false because
well let's just put return false so
yeah we could put the return false
earlier but we assume that if it goes
through this without executing it's
going to return false but if it does
execute then what do we do now this is a
thing we need to think about here
if it's a heal potion so let's just
check if potion dot oh it's a pointer
peel amount it's greater than
zero
then let's increase our health and we
have health because we this is a whole
player character whole player character
set up so we just go
pc class dot
or let's see we have a heal yeah we
should have a heal function somewhere
that we've designed earlier let's see if
we can find it
hp maybe i i forget exactly it's been a
while
but maybe we have an increase do we have
an increased function is that what we
called it
i totally forget okay let's have a look
way up top at our player character
delegates i believe we have it in here i
mean we do have
hp of course
and it is actually public so we can
access it and do whatever we want but we
want to make sure it doesn't you know go
too high
and that sort of thing so we should
actually use the functions uh that that
do that sort of thing
i thought we did yeah we have an
increased current so we call increase
current
uh
kind of tricky here because technically
you're allowed to increase it above its
current if you just access it directly
so maybe we need to rethink that a
little bit but just a little heads up
there if anyone wants to play around
with that on the github that would be
cool
but not fair enough
uh
so we need to call this on the hp so we
go pc class hp
uh increased current that's what it was
and it would just be by this heal amount
like so that way it doesn't overheal we
have this
this increased current designed in a way
where it can't take you over your max so
that's what we want to use we want to
we'll do a little delegating there
and that's based on this whole point
well class
all right so that should work
and that should heal us if it has a heal
so also another thing we could do you
know the heal amount's always going to
be something we don't necessarily need
to even check we can just straight up
call
look at this and call increase current
and if it doesn't heal for anything it
doesn't heal for anything but uh i don't
think that's going to cause any problems
right now it just reduces the number of
checks we need to do and it will make it
a little more efficient uh
and we already know so yeah we have some
pointers here that we're not checking in
this function like this is a pointer
this is a unique pointer we should in
theory be checking if they're null but
because of the way we've designed this
earlier
we know for a fact that pc class has to
be instantiated and we know that hp has
to be instantiated so in our current
design we don't really need to check
those although they're being really
technical you know a lot of static
analysis stuff is going to pick this up
and be like hey you're using these
pointers on a function and you haven't
checked if they're null it's going to
it's going to kind of complain but we
just know off the design that they can't
be null
all right so that we have that and we
also want to check the buff now buff we
know for sure can be null if
potion buff and that'll just be a check
if that is true then it buffs and we're
just gonna call
apply buff of whatever this potion is
fly buff
and whatever the potion is ocean
spell correctly there
and now this wants
a non-pointer so we have to de-reference
it with this star
that just says get the actual data uh
because of the way we designed the
supply buff which forwards to the you
know okay oh my goodness this is a
there's a crazy function this isn't
something that probably needs to
redesign now i'm looking at it just
there's too many layers that it's
confusing but basically all this does is
apply a buff give it the duration all
that good stuff
so yeah it applies the the buff that
whatever your potion does
back up a few times go back down to
where we were
use item here it is
and now if we ended up using this potion
we need to produce the quantity so at
this point
we would go
uh potion
quantity
minus minus
that just reduces it
so now we need to think about another
thing all right so what if there's zero
now what if there's zero potions
uh i guess we just delete it right if
potion dot quantity is zero
then we destroy it but
do we really want to do that here in the
use or do we want that to happen in some
sort of cleanup phase
that's something i haven't decided yet
but yeah i guess we would just do it
here delete
potion so what this is going to do
is it's going to free the memory of
course
and it's going to
call
destructors this is kind of a scary
function to use
i don't actually know if this will work
correctly i don't i don't know if this
is going to be something that's going to
cause problems because of this dynamic
cast so maybe a little scary there
but in theory you know if it is a potion
it'll just you know delete
this and it'll call this destructor
which will delete the the buff and if it
needs to and everything else about this
potion will just get deleted and it
should be fine but
we also have to think about what's going
to happen with our inventory and how is
our inventory going to be managing this
memory too
but for now
that should be fine so let's go back to
our main now we made this potion here
and we have data but
the pointer will go out of scope right
here so let's go ahead and leave it in
scope by just doing that sort of thing
because
we're going to go ahead and use this
heal potion and just see what happens so
let's go
somewhere in our in our guide or
class here now our guy hasn't taken any
damage it's not really going to work
to just i'm sure we could use them but
if we're full then kind of what's the
point basically right
so maybe we need a case in here and i'm
not going to do this but just to explain
a little logic in avoiding bugs what if
you try to use a heel potion
specifically a hill potion doesn't even
have a buff but you're already at full
hp what would you want to happen if it
was your game well you would want it to
say
no basically it's like i won't use it
you're already at full it doesn't have a
buff to apply so that's not relevant
so we could have a case in here uh like
let's see i guess we would do okay maybe
we'd do it after this check here
so maybe we do this buff check first and
apply the buff and then increase the
current
so maybe we could go
if
let's see we already have access to the
character pc class
uh hp
now i mean we probably want to like it
is full method is full
so let's just design that is full and
ocean
not buff are not potion
so if your hp is full and there's no
buff just
uh
well let's you we want to return false
basically
earn false
so
i don't use the potion
you know i said we weren't going to do
this but it's easy enough to actually do
that we're just going to do it if we end
up getting all the way to the bottom
we're going to return true because if we
get to
if we get all the way here we've
actually used the potion so we have to
think about this very very carefully
let's go ahead and design this function
it doesn't exist let's go to our hp here
let's go to our point well and uh why
not we should have a method
that just checks if it's full or not
current fullness we have a max and we
just want to see if that the current and
the max are equal basically so
public
yeah
let's just do it right here because it's
a getter
uh bull
is full
and we'll just return current fullness
equal equal max which is just going to
check
if the current
and the max
are the same and if they are returns
true means we're full if they're not
it's going to be false means we're not
full a little simple function that'll
just help i mean it makes sense to have
that in a point well
i think
there we go all right let's go back down
here to our use function and i think
we're pretty good here so now if we walk
through this
uh we can think about it you know uh the
obvious null checks here
and
you know there's more things okay let's
walk through this but i'm going to
change this just just a little bit i
think here in a second let me just check
something here so
all right i'll explain in a second i
hope i don't forget to come back to what
i'm thinking but i want to finish
walking through this all right so we
check if it's a potion
and if it is we try to apply it
basically
if it has a buff we apply the buff
[Music]
so this will get skipped if it doesn't
have a buff that's really important for
our logic here
all right and if your hp is full
and it doesn't apply a buff we
return we get out of here before we
reduce the quantity basically
otherwise this gets skipped if your hp
is not full or if it applies a buff
we're going to continue down this line
so go ahead and go ahead and heal for
whatever heals maybe it's a zero maybe
it's not it doesn't really matter but
it's it's we at least need to continue
but this case here is for
hey if you're max health and you try to
use the heel potion basically
right let's make this clear if max
health
and trying to use a heel
potion uh
don't use it yeah so that that's it
i think that's pretty clear
and this that's what this will do now we
could have this down here but it doesn't
matter really a whole lot because we've
already already kind of addressed that
so there's some things where order has
to be really precise and other things
where you got a little bit of play in
the order and this is one of those
things where we have a bit of play so
it's actually fine like this all right
but you know really we should have more
comments apply buff if
it has
what
uh attempt uh well just increase hp
by the heal amount could be zero and
that's fine
all right
we use the potion
reduce
quantity
now there's something else interesting
here
we could create potions with quantity
zero it's possible we could do it
we look at the item manager we could
pass at a zero it would still create it
with zero and it would just not work
it would be weird so let's just
let's just not allow that all right if
you're if you're making a potion
what what exactly is the point of making
zero
there wouldn't be if so quantity let's
just say if your quantity is zero
then we make it one that's it we're just
we're just being a little pedantic here
now there's other ways to do this
actually let's do it with a little
ternary operator here
it's backwards
here we go
so we'll do it in line here
there we go
spelling that's wrong
oh i i let i always forget the order no
that's fine it's just you know visual
studio underlying things when it doesn't
need to sometimes okay so what this does
in case you don't know about it it's a
ternary operator it's just an n line if
else basically says if the quantity is
zero return one otherwise return the
quantity so that way they can't make
zero potions all right
just in case they try to pass zero to
this item count at least one potion
all right then that'll that'll get rid
of that whole bug case because
yeah that could be crazy we could
what could end up happening if we don't
do that and we keep this function as it
is is it could do all this stuff
and then when we go to use up the potion
it would already be zero so the quantity
would minus minus but what happens when
you minus minus
an unsigned integer that's already zero
it wraps to the max value so they would
suddenly have 32 million potions
and this quantity would not be zero so
it wouldn't delete it
they would basically get 32 million
potions if we left that buck in there
and the spiffing brit would just be like
now what we can you know he would do his
thing get to get millions of potions and
break our game
and uh we just don't allow that that's
that's by this simple bit of logic and a
little bit of forethought
hire me bethesda
and there we go i think we've walked
through that now the thing i wanted to
come back to this is all about coding
standards
uh there's
we see it often actually when i reviewed
the bungee coding standards from their
article one of their standards was
you only have one place in your function
where you return you don't want to have
returns all over the place because it
makes the function confusing
so i just want to make an example of how
you would do that because it's kind of
important to know basically all you do
is you have a return value at the top
return
oh
we want this to be bolding of course
this is one way to do it
and we'll just default it to true
and now anytime
we do this sort of check we'll just go
return value equals
false if it would be false and now this
kind of convolutes things in my opinion
because now as you go through the rest
of this
you always got to be checking what your
return value is because like once it's
false we don't want to do the rest of
this we just want to skip to the end and
return it so now what you have to do and
this is where it gets painful is you
just always need to
check here
um we gotta knot it
and basically in any of these checks
we need to always be rechecking what the
return value would be so yeah it's a
it's a trade-off uh if you're not
allowed to return yet then as you go
forward and the rest of the stuff you
might do you gotta you always be
checking hey is the return value already
false because if so we need to be
skipping to the bottom
uh so we could do that uh
like so
because this will say now if we think
about it okay
let's default the return value to true
let's assume this is going to be
successful first of all are they passing
in a non-null item
if not
return value is false it's going to fail
and
yeah we're actually done here so if we
should in theory return here
but as you can see this is going to just
get messy so i
i don't really do that ever i don't
prefer that coding standard i just think
it becomes
uh even it's
it's a pick your poison sort of search
situation i'm okay with returning
false and getting out of the function
because you know once you return you
don't go any further and that's intended
so you just need to consider that in
your logic it's all but you know do what
your company requires in general
uh if you're working for someone else or
with a big team rather where everyone's
trying to follow the same standards but
you know in some ways i can see how it'd
be beneficial to do it that way but in
other ways it's like i'm already so used
to doing my logic in this way where i
just return
the proper thing if it gets to a case
where i should
that work i'm going to keep it like that
but yeah that that was all
okay there we go now these
we still need to do the inventory
we're out of time for today so we're not
going to but it's the same case with
these items
we are going to
well once we have an inventory we're
going to update this to pass in a
reference to the inventory because you
got to be using your potion from
somewhere so we essentially want to know
what inventory are you using out of so
that we can reduce the quantity in the
proper inventory or delete it
uh out of the proper inventory
so we'll keep these to do's here and we
will get to this inventory hopefully
next episode
but that's it for this one just getting
those potions all worked out i hope that
makes sense okay we need to use it let's
let's do a quick use this will be the
last thing so we created a potion it's
just a heel potion our
our poor warrior is not missing any
health so
he's he's fine he doesn't need to use a
potion but let's just for sake of
example
uh we'll make this item later
let's go down to the very bottom all
right i mean
let's just delete some lines here let's
go down to the very bottom after we've
made all our stuff done all our stuff
and let's take damage
and we can do this by
just calling take
damage let's have him
take four damage all right that should
reduce his current we have this function
designed in that way and go check it out
and we see we got reduce amount
yadda yadda does its thing
and it makes sure that it can't go below
zero we designed that like in episode
two or something a long time ago don't
remember exactly but back to our main
so he's going to take a little damage
the the point of this is he's actually
going to be able to use the heel pose
let's go ahead and create that heel
potion and let's go p1 dot use heal
potion
and now let's just check his health all
right so let's just do a standard
well we'll do it before and after the
use just to make sure it's actually
standard c out
uh health
before
using potion and also another thing on
our to-do list
we gotta design proper tests so we'll
probably have a full episode on just
making tests for as many things as we
can
in the allotted time and i'm sure we
won't get to all of them
but at least give you
a sample of how to do it all right
health before using potion p1 dot we
have a get hp i forget
get current hb
and we'll put a new line character here
and let's just do this after
after and we'll do some stuff like this
here health for
taking
damage spill taking right
now
after taking damage
i guess we don't need this one here
because it's going to be the same health
after using potion okay so there we go
this should be like his max health or
whatever
hold on let's let's do a little
cockbuster
let's use this function
or this will call out because
it does it has the nice little slash
which i like
uh
yeah there it is
it's just gonna say current slash max
that way we can see exactly how much he
has and i'm just going to copy this in
all of them now yeah i'm obviously doing
a hack job in this main because this
main is all temporary it's the one thing
that doesn't matter at all okay so
we have a little something complaining
we're probably just missing semicolons
yep
yep okay
very good so let's run this
and we just want to look at the very
bottom here once all this runs oh we
have errors this is fine we're kind of
expected to have something it's unlikely
that we got everything perfect on the
first try
i think we don't need this semicolon
right
well we don't need that semicolon there
that's true
however we got something else
complaining about
okay doesn't know what this buff is we
haven't included buff pretty sure that's
all it is
it just has no idea okay
looks like we got a few other new things
the stat block also doesn't know what
buff is uh oh we got maybe a circular
include here so we gotta address that
this rather carefully uh we got a vector
here knows what that okay that's fine
now this is the the mess of header only
you gotta really carefully do the order
of these
might be the stat block i'm pretty sure
we're not actually using stat block in
this buff no we're only using core stats
so that might be it
just got to be really careful that
you're only including the things you are
actually using
all right so let's have a look here
uh-oh we'll see that it doesn't work
correctly let's we'll be sure to fix
this before we end the episode health
before taking damage 27-27 after take
damage works fine health after using
potion
now we can see that it does not go up
why not
all right and now we're going to do a
little debugging so let's go into our
player character
let's go into that use function
and let's just put a break point right
here now let's find out
why it doesn't heal
uh we might be returning wrong
here because that'll return true if
they're full false otherwise
so if this returns true yeah we're
returning false here so we want to say
this should be an and
that's the thing here
all right maybe you caught that earlier
if so good job because this this needs
both cases to be true basically and in
our case this one was
this one was
false
and that would flip it to true all right
well now it should work so let's get rid
of this break point let's just say play
again and see if that was actually it
yes
that was actually it okay
so you gotta just carefully think about
that logic sometimes so all right so
yeah that looks good health before
taking damage full
takes four damage goes down to 23 uses a
heal potion we designed our heel potion
to heal for three it does go up by three
as intended
very good now of course we have more
cases to test like what if he's only
missing one hit point make sure it
doesn't overheal them stuff like that
let's take one damage and run the same
thing see if it's any different and yep
there we go we see it there it's not
overhealing or anything everything's
working great
very cool
all right and that is this episode
of making potions and being able to use
those consumables and hopefully next
episode we actually get to design the
inventory that as of right now is the
plan and so look forward to that
happy coding and i'll see you guys next
time peace out
you